I want to talk I'm sitting with Brad
Williams and Jeff died both comedians
allegedly we're the road dogs and you
guys I feel like we're the both of the
first guys who have gone and performed
yeah live comedy since this whole thing
yeah we weren't wiseguys this weekend
yeah and I was near there next weekend
right yeah and I was at not virtually we
flew there and flew there we did the
whole thing and so crazy how was that
Brickton comedy yeah Oklahoma City so
yeah
explain to me I was at wise guys in Salt
Lake City yeah just blaming me why it's
crazy well I guess me my first I guess
like I don't know I don't have any fear
of like people coming to the event I
don't never need my thoughts anyway I
never thought about that I had thoughts
about like as a comedian being onstage
since there's gonna be less people in
the audience
yeah would I feel like bummed out what I
feel like this isn't the same like what
I feel like and then I started thinking
from a business standpoint like okay
well is this business even gonna make
enough money like are these waitresses
gonna make enough money tonight like
I'll tell you who didn't make enough
money the comedian
yeah they've got a reason to go hey man
we have a limited audience yeah yeah so
you know it's only we have to cab them
out at a hundred I can't like work a
bonus deal or anything like that so that
was it but the waitress made great money
they did yes yes because everyone's
audiences on and you guys will both know
this and maybe anyone that listens that
isn't a commune you might not know but
audiences are famously and more so than
ever now that park has blown up people
people didn't use to know comedians they
just went to the Improv and they did
maybe I hope to be a famous person and
all the other communities maybe like
this is great I would say in the last
eight years I've witnessed with the
success of you and Segura and basically
everyone that's on this wall right is
now people if they haven't seen you
before they're like who's this guy I've
never heard of him and then the vibe
shifts to this weird like make me laugh
[ __ ] like that's the vibe where I'm
unfunny til proven funny and then it
kind of is like oh he is funny and I
have never even heard of him cuz I
listen to all the podcasts I'm shocked
that someone is funny but I don't know
right where is that totally changed yeah
this weekend dude people were so
generous like one dude tipped our server
like 200 bucks
you were gushing to me like oh my god
thank you sir it was they were just so
happy I'm yeah I was crushing on like
throwaway lines like so was very
generous yeah did you feel um what were
some of you guys as fears going into it
before we even talked about what the
weekend with with the weekends were like
like did you have any like just our
thoughts even just thoughts yeah I
wasn't worried about the shows and in
terms of like you look out in the
audience and sounds different because
it's at a third capacity or a half
capacity or whatever it is my philosophy
is okay or I could stay home and there's
no show there's no one laughs there's
nothing there's nothing you know so and
yeah you're not gonna just flip flip a
switch and we all come back and it's
exactly the way it was we we got an a
Clemente gradually get into it and you
know kind of test the waters a little
bit and then if it's good then we'll
move them up to the next level I was
more worried about the travel than
anything that and it was for me like the
worst part for me wasn't the shows I
love the shows that the audience's much
like you said were great they were so
starved for content they want to go out
they wanted to have fun but traveling
that was weird because you had to wear
the masks the whole time which when you
go to the grocery store it's like okay
it's an hour but when you're flying when
I'm flying to Oklahoma City that's six
hours we don't realize how much you try
to drinks yeah that's six hours of
wearing a mask and then like my ears are
hurting you know you know yeah and like
they're not they're not serving food on
the plane so you got like if it's a long
flight you're like okay I got a snack up
before I get on and we're the seat
spaced out and your flights more without
that Southwest was American Airlines and
not give it you two you're too famous to
fly south this guy's flying South one
there's four South ninety eight bucks
hey you got it so I flew from LAX to
Salt Lake City yeah and so excited to
Seattle Seattle to LAX because they
cancel always like legs of flight right
right right on your trip home there was
nobody in the airports nobody on my
flight that was kind of eerie but that's
pretty safe I mean like if I see no
people I'm not afraid yeah also I will
say and I know this is gonna annoy all
the liberal New York comedians that I'm
gonna say this but I dealt with the
pretty like selfishly
mmm-hmm like I was like I'm not afraid I
want to go tell jokes I'm wearing the
mask out of respect for others if you
want
come hug me I don't give a [ __ ] like I'm
so well and also like don't care like
right like for you personally you're in
that group that according to the science
it's like you should be fine
it like you don't have an immune problem
you're a healthy guy you got a big dick
like like you like you I will say the
people that come to my shows yeah
obviously seem to not care either right
and I don't so if they get me sick I get
them sick [ __ ] them
yeah they come out yeah they came out
yeah and so it's like I'm not hurting
gram gram she's at home right I'm and I
know that that's a selfish take and I'm
admitting that I'm selfish because I
just want to get back to comedy so bad
yeah and I'm so tired of being at my
house with my dog I tried to do one of
those virtual shows had a great time but
it wasn't the same yeah and so I need to
I needed it I needed to like my I need
my hotel rooms I need to flirt with
girls I need to tell jokes I needed some
sort of semblance of what I'm used to
whenever you got to the club like did
you feel like where did they seem really
really excited to like be back in
business like yeah they were stoked and
the waitstaff was stoked because they
had a job you know that's like people
were happy man yeah yeah it's I mean
I'll respect anyone's wishes if they
want to stay home if they want to go out
whatever but like I understand when you
say oh all the restaurants are closed
there's some people there that just okay
they can't they can't hunker down for
three four months and then be fine like
their rent does dude they got the guy
they gotta buy food they got to do all
these things like so I respect that if
they if they're like no I have to go
work so and also we weren't out of the
beach like yeah like laying on each
other and sweating and stuff well I was
at a comedy club in and that literally
like everybody that came in had to keep
the temperature taken yeah okay the plan
is sanitized really had to wear masks to
come in they had to wear their masks on
the way out
when they get sat at their table the
tables are six feet apart right there's
no party larger than four mm-hmm each
comic had their own separate microphone
that were sanitized in between the shop
so I mean there's a safe way to do this
did you bring your mic from jokingly
brought up mic from home to do like gag
that Isis gag where there's gonna be
breath there's gonna be bad sorry
it was it was bad if you see me at the
store and then you see me do it again in
the improv like I just saw does it yeah
so the joke is like I would come out I
did this way before the quarantine I
would come out and I would like look
like I was like disgusted with like the
microphone and I would like take it out
and then put it on the table and then
I'd pull out like gold microphone out of
my back pocket and just act like and
then and then everyone like laughs
because they were like so confused by me
doing the first part right and then I'd
be like yeah you know they don't clean
those things and it just makes me look
like this elitist kind of guy like that
the problem with that bit is it's
hilarious if I'm following like that you
know drew that stuttering guy if I'm
following you know Theo or something but
if I'm following like Miss Pat and I
just come out I'm like what the hell was
that man yeah just do like a racist like
so that's why yeah I stopped doing it I
bet Billy doesn't you're like you know
those people yeah you know those people
that aren't welcome at the VFW you know
what I'm talking about and I'm so dumb
that I didn't put that together I was
just like why did nobody laugh this time
looks like an and so I stopped doing it
but then as Jamar neighbors went on
before you so I brought that same mic
and did the same gag each show for this
oh that's fun yeah cuz there was four
mics for all asked to take one of those
mics down and I'm gonna pretend like
they didn't leave me a mic and I'm just
gonna have to like do the gag that I
brought my own yeah and that's the thing
is like you said like there's there's
precautions that you could take so it's
definitely like it's not yes the say the
safest thing would be to just stay in
your homes and throw a blanket over you
and never leave your house yeah that's
the safest thing but there are there are
ways to do these shows that it's like
okay yeah take temperatures stay spread
apart and no no one was sat at a table
with someone who didn't know so like wow
it's so it's like yeah if you came in
the same car together you sat at the
same and I had a virus I feel fine what
else at the place I didn't think about
the mics so the microphones on stage
because I'm just trying to think like
yeah to me it did it feel like you guys
were pioneers like did you guys feel
like holy [ __ ] like I didn't think I was
until I got back
I posted I've put you didn't post yours
I post on Instagram I posted all mine on
all on all the stuff just say hey I'm
out comedy's back let's do this come to
the shows let's have a good time blah
blah yeah and I must have gotten and I'm
not exaggerating probably 40 people 40
comics either text or call to the next
day looking for work looking at the same
was that like oh yeah yeah every - oh
yeah I've never any Letterman's never
called my phone in my life yeah like
will do snotty text back and forth like
there I'm like stoned at a hotel and
Annie Lederman yeah she's great to sext
with even though neither one y'all's
gonna hook up with each other
hey I know Joe and he's great for that
know that she just loves like
conversations you're like sexy yeah I
was bad on the phone with her I was like
kind of like I didn't expect anyone to
call I don't knows I shouldn't even
answer yeah I got I got a few comics
calling me too it's like like it's like
you guys know that it's just like it's a
comedy or right same like it was it was
the same
it was the same yeah there's a few less
people I was more bummed that like in
between shows or during the daytime I
couldn't walk around like do things in
the city I did do though bombed about
that I did that but it was just the same
as kind of California like where you I
walked like a coffee shop I was able to
have coffee there mm-hmm
I like set like this park there was a
bar that had like an open patio you
could sit on there you go so that was
kind of nice and I was giddy I wouldn't
shut up I was sitting with two friends
yeah and I just like was motormouth cuz
I was so excited to be back like in the
sunshine I've had it with like a cold if
you like food and I was like being able
to just do yeah because I've been in my
house man yeah yeah and you were so you
were in Oklahoma City yeah and and that
and that was rough because that that
Club it's a great club it's in the
middle of this downtown area called
brick town and like I got sad walking
around during the day because it's like
there's a minor-league baseball park
right there Oklahoma City Dodgers play
and then the the Thunder stadium is
right there too and there's a big movie
theater there's a Riverwalk there's all
this stuff I'm like wow if this was all
open this would I could go to a baseball
game during the day come early see the
Thunder play see a movie like it would
have been a whole great weekend so that
so that clubs gonna be fantastic once
once everything starts opening up again
it's gonna be great but that one's the
club the sanam Norwest
yeah that's the deck yeah okay yeah the
same people that do Tacoma it looked
like they packed them kind of in on
yours I saw a picture to show cuz I
could say I'm fine any of the stuff I
was looking for yours yeah when he told
me you does it I didn't cuz I mean we
talked about you going to wiseguys yeah
yeah and it starts looking for it and I
only could find like a dude tag doing a
photo from like the back green room area
yeah yeah where the seats were yeah are
you nervous about putting it on social
media I was I put it on Instagram
because that's people that follow you
that like they like you they love you I
was I didn't put it on Twitter because I
was nervous that someone would start
retweeting it I was hoping someone would
start calling me an [ __ ] for bein
goddamn living go ahead yeah laser
talking about being your such a hero for
staying home with your parents go ahead
come at me oh how heroic you millionaire
you had sex for two months get a life
you could don't you Nikki you do grosser
things all the time bragging about anal
sex
I think worried about a virus yeah yeah
wear a face mask on your behold it if
you want to really take care there's
some sort of weird like hero is it like
oh we're such heroes there is well I
noticed too that there's this thing
where I think a lot of people want you
to stay home because it gives them and
I'm not saying this about Nikki but just
it gives them a sense of control control
and a sense of like okay I don't have to
do anything nobody can do anything
there's the photo it keeps him in a safe
space yeah that's the one I was
referring to yeah sitting close to each
other wow that's nice man yeah well they
only look close to each other compared
to where I play it I guess well that and
it's like okay I mean I'll tell you that
from this stage this is a weird angle
because yes it looks very close to each
other but it's like those photos of the
beach were there where they're like
so-and-so's on the beach you know all
the all the people and then if you
really zoom in you're like oh no people
are separate yeah like they're not like
they're not like throwing a towel like
on top of each other like in the NFL
they always air the game from the side
so it looks like those linemen are right
next to each other but if there was a
good Birds Eye view or fries north to
south yeah there's either
there's Gabby yeah yeah II guess so yeah
or like whenever you get it catch a fish
member if you caught a fish you put in
the back of a fake truck remember and
took that picture you're like look at
this big fish and it was just a um
little fish yeah dude it was great and
they all obviously do that they uh they
all had a great time and yeah it was
just so like I got so many messages
afterwards yeah
for everyone's want to know yeah and all
my scared friends gone uh-huh yeah and
you doing that yeah it's almost like you
guys are almost like the Neil Armstrong
and whoever the and Buzz ultra and I
feel like I'm comedy I'm not even joking
man it was like I was like oh my god
because I've been taking a break from
heaven gasps that's having guests on the
podcast it's been really tired and so
yeah but I was like oh my god I said I
just have to know about this well and I
think yeah that's bread yeah there we go
oh nice it's a good shot I'm up there
yeah cuz I didn't do a meet and greet
afterward so I had a moment where I was
like alright everyone take take out your
phones and I'm gonna do some poses on
the stage so you can like have a photo
and post on your social media because I
don't want to do a meeting greet so I
started like grabbing the mic saying
like doing stuff that I would never do
actually during my act and I thought
social distancing I'll just wave a mic
stand around my face and let's be strong
man those mic stands are compact biceps
I also want to go in and uh was Brad
Williams Brad Williams comic a Trev
Williams comic was amazing funny as hell
for someone so little that's the comment
funny is all for so much so look what do
you think a tiny person telling jokes
isn't gonna be good laughs would be one
third of they fit all a funny and that
little guy would be funny god I will
admit my mean Greek got it responsible
that is yeah cuz you know I'm talking a
big game on stage acting like I don't
care I'm doing all these jokes about how
like Isaac I did get my coronavirus from
some Millennials sneezing hominin uber
when I heard about it I ordered bats I
ate a bat that's what I did
I want from the source I got it the
right way so I'm doing all these like
and that's riling them up a little you
know and so it's riling them up in the
worst way we're like yeah [ __ ] these
masks what do we you know and that's the
worst I'm that's irresponsible but I was
just doing accounting and then
afterwards of the mean grid they're like
hey can we get photo with you and I said
yeah you want a mask or no mask they're
like dude we don't care about that
touch it like that it did get a little
yeah oh yeah you get a but you get
nervous at that point a little yeah then
yeah then the guy's like starting to
lick your face and stuff
they're obviously you know it's
interesting it's like it's definitely
become I think a lot of people that are
it's like you know do I am i risking
getting sick or am I just do I think
that this thing is kind of run its
course do I feel like we've done
everything that we can is like about
flattening the curve it's always kind of
two weeks you know every time they say
like Oh two weeks for this two weeks to
that I think you just got to make your
decision yeah it's like you know I would
never judge anyone for wearing gloves
out in public and doing the mask and
like keeping it I think that's great
yeah I just if you don't want to do that
that you know like what's that one guy
God he gave us like free will yeah yeah
we love that about it
we love that he lets us do it well like
whatever this consequence is all right
yeah that's your yeah that because
that's the way that I feel a lot of
times I'm still gonna be smart and wise
I've always had I feel like decent
instincts so I'm gonna trust my
instincts yeah and and like like my
parents are both like 75 and my dad's my
dad's immune compromised he should not
be right going out and if you're gonna
go hang out with them you shouldn't be I
should go get tested like like if if
grandma's living with you at your house
then then you have a different
responsibility so we're not saying like
everyone just go out but if you're young
healthy 30 30 year old 20 year old and
you're like I want to go just have a
little bit of fun yeah and there's a
very bounce it was a very few times
someone was in like my bubble right to
be honest like if I look over the entire
weekend there was very few times that it
was it was even that close to me yeah
yeah there really is actually whenever
you go to a comedy club there's not
there's really aren't a lot of times
it's separate when you're in the green
room with other comics there's not a lot
of times and if you don't do
meet-and-greet then there's not a lot of
times where you interact like real to
close with other people really you come
out on stage yeah I mean you're almost
really the safest person in the room in
a lot of ways that is the community that
was my that was my thought and I even I
even when I was doing my show I even
tried to be at the back of the stage cuz
I thought oh if I talk and like I said
it out and because I've done that before
where I've been on stage and I've said
something and I and I watch the spill oh
yeah oh yeah advice and it's like oh
that's going right yeah oh that guys
getting I have one guy walk on the
Friday Early Show because we had all the
microphones out there of all three of
them I guess but I told him to strike
one of them and then I use the thing and
so the other two microphones are just
behind me with the things in and I'm
saying like right guys are we really
that scared even the people that are the
most scared who claim that they're the
most scared of this there they're all
they're all at home going would you
watch tiger king and singing just
sending each other like big black guy
dick names like nobody's really that
afraid if this is the end of the world
like no one seems to really be that
scared and so the people are like you
know cheering and so I got right we're
not afraid and I just started palming
the other mics like Oh laughs the other
comics like Mike's like with my bare
hands
well that's also because you're in Utah
and that basketball player Rudy egg no
no Rudy Gobert I thought it would be
funny like to do like a thing like that
also they sanitized those mics in
between and I'm the last guy so that
we're gonna sanitize those in ours so I
thought it's funny everyone's like I'm
gonna laugh and this dude was [ __ ]
furious he like stood up he like went to
the front what is he doing it I mean
this is the whole thing is that we were
doing this responsibly and he's like
kind of in the middle then that guys
like yeah well and you also watch the
whole show with his mask on he had like
like the entire most people took the
mask off for the show and then they put
the mask back on yeah the whole thing
brave is that guy though think about
that like if in your head that's where
you are fear why I wanted to go to a
place yeah and you're like yeah I'll
make myself do this yeah it's my wife's
birthday yeah and like I said if you
want if you want to stay home I'm not
gonna make fun of anyone for wanting to
stay home like to stay home it's fun but
then if someone wants to go out and be
responsible and you know it's like yeah
if you're if you're walking up to people
and strangers and spitting on them or
licking their faces okay you're kind of
a dick but yeah but if everyone's kind
of like playing their part and doing
their thing
okay we can start we start coming back
to what we saw what we had before
what am I making it sound like just by
leaving your home at any time to do
anything you're a part of the problem
like you must be some Republican crazy
person yeah thinks this virus isn't real
it's like no there's ways to go about
your life and try to earn some money and
try to like a job or try to maintain
groceries there's ways that you can go
do your life yeah oh no I a safe and
responsible not as what it was but yeah
I think our being responsible yeah yeah
I had someone yell at me in my
neighborhood for taking my dog for a
walk because I met my mask on it's like
no one no one walks toward no one walks
towards us no one does anything I'm
taking my dog for a walk like that and
and I got in I have an 80 pound pitbull
I need to be able to breathe and have
some oxygen to watch one time I should
sell tickets and just me walking my dog
it's a [ __ ] walking a pitfall ya know
it's just so cool on an only fans I'd
watch that i watch so what what else was
there like from the shows I'm trying to
think like after the show like did the
energy did the energy feel the same like
in the room during the show yeah but
more I thought more just as everyone was
just so excited to be out like and there
were lines that I would say that I would
thought like alright this kind of a
throwaway line and just something casual
and that it would get a reaction I'm
like oh yeah it felt like a full room
for ya really yeah like that's awesome
I wrote a real basic joke about how like
like every when the virus happened every
company had had to put out their
coronavirus commercial where they're
just like every commercial right now
it's just stuff it starts off we're
gonna get through this yeah like we can
we get that in trying times and all I
said was like does every we don't need
every company's response to coronavirus
and there was a cheer in the room I'm
like oh yeah that's true though okay
people feel that way yeah it's like I
it's like I get it
AT&T insurance let let me know what
you're doing to lower my rates or
whatever but there's literally a
commercial from Oreo [ __ ] cookie yeah
I was getting emails from like Wells
Fargo like don't worry yeah I'm not
worried about you your bank you'll be
fine you're in class we're fine yeah can
we our ATMs are clean in it yes or like
start like
yeah yeah yeah it's like Coca Cola's
like here's what we're doing it's like
ya know you're you're making sugar water
that's what you're doing it's fine
though I would say the thing I was most
most nervous about and again this is
selfish I just thought I might be rusty
this is the longest oh god once - 15
years so I was like I was afraid I'd be
rusty but then being so generous and
then also I realized I wasn't that rusty
like I was I felt rusty on that virtual
show did it feel weird did it feel weird
going back into like like cause like if
I were to get back on stage I'm like I
have some new stuff I would kind of do
but otherwise it's like you got to
change all the bits and I was like just
in the verbage so I could you know I
usually get up there and go I just got
back from Mexico so I go to all my
Mexico stuff right I can't sit okay or
like if I want to make a joke about
something that happened between me and a
girl I'll usually lie and be like oh I
took this girl on a date like you know
the other day or like last week yeah now
I can say that yeah I had to be like oh
I remember I think it was last year I
took this girl on a date yeah but even
that little adjustment was hard to do
like anything so dishonest and like so
but I don't know I haven't been doing
anything right yeah there there there's
a bit I do about how like I'm it's
something that my neighbor said to me
because I'm never home I'm always
traveling yeah so then my neighbor saw
me in front of my house and then said
something to me like I didn't live in my
house right it's like I can't do that no
it's because it's like no no I've been
home for three months they know me now I
would start jokes like I would start
talking the guy I got to change this
like a you know that quick math you do
in your head right that's like it over
yeah I'm only a comic would notice
they're only like I you know yeah